Yo tout le monde c'est Fabien
Aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour un test de jeu vidéo
Et plus précisément on va "challenger" Squeezie à un jeu qu'il a fait le 24 mai dernier
Pourquoi je fais cette vidéo ?
Pour deux raisons. La première, je mets mes lunettes j'ai trente ans passé qu'est ce que tu veux ?
La première c'est parce que j'avais vu cette vidéo mais vous m'en avait parlé dans les commentaires et j'ai trouvé que c'était une bonne idée
La deuxième c'est que le 24 mai dernier Squeezie était malade dans cette vidéo. Il y a peut-être une chance que j'arrive à marquer des points
On va clairement tester les capacités de notre cerveau et voir si toutes les méthodes dont je parle pour améliorer ces capacités un peu cognitives
Qui est quand même l'un des premiers but du mentalisme
Permet de faire un score acceptable ou pas
Pour le Number Memory ils disent quelque chose de vrai en générale un être humain retient 7 choses, 7 objets, 7 chiffres
Dans sa vidéo Squeezie avait été très bon puisqu'il était allé jusqu'au treizième ce qui est vraiment bien
Il avait raté le treizième donc ça veux dire que jusqu'au douzième il avait juste
Alors, d'accord ça s'affiche et ça note. Donc là 3 c'est tranquille. 34 ça va il n'y a pas besoin de mnémotechnie encore
D'ailleurs j'en profite pour vous dire arrêtez de me dire que je fais des fautes à mnémotechnie. Non, ça s'écrit comme je l'écris moi: M N, Mnémo
Et pas "mémo-technie"
Euh c'était quoi ?
T'imagines je rate le numéro 3. On voit que c'est vraiment que c'est à partir de 7 que ça se corse
on arrive moins à grouper en fait
170.43.195
Là ça va. A la limite j'ai besoin de rien
En fait là j'ai utilisé ce qu'on appelle la boucle phonologique
c'est à dire que je l'ai répété et ça reste dans ma mémoire temporaire
494.009.720
007 pour James Bond
mais je sais que c'est 9 parce que j'avais un 9 au début mais du coup mon 7 je le mets après
et 7+2 = 9 et après je mets mon zéro
c'est hyper chelou mais du coup ça va trop vite pour le détailler
449.483.07.90
Ok là ça va. Ça me fait encore des dates et des dessins en tête
24 février
24 février, 5 mars 94 mais sans les zéro
et 76 avec le zéro
Là je l'ai encore parce qu'il était très simple. Je vous explique
j'ai gagné 2 fois en 98, au football. C'était où? c''était à Paris
et à la fin il y a 60 personnes qui se sont battus contre 70 personnes
on a dû être obliger d'appeler 8 fois les pompiers
Okay on arrive au moment fatidique où Squeezie avait perdu
et c'est là que ça me mets la pression
sachant que lui était malade ce jour là
Je pense que je l'ai
Alors au début je me suis fait une série logique 25.26.23
après 920 tout court
et après 41.32
C'est bon on a passé Squeezie
bon on a passé un Squeezie malade mais on l'a passé quand même
alors là je m'arrête là parce que le but, c'est vraiment de faire juste le challenge
jeu par jeu je vais essayer de faire mieux ou moins bien pour le prochain
il y a de forte chance
Et si vraiment ce genre de vidéos vous plait, vous me le dites dans les commentaires, vous pouvez aussi euh...
mais je l'ai pas dit
Et dans ces cas là je pourrais vous faire une vidéo où j'essaie d'y aller jusqu'à temps que je perde
ça se trouve c'est au coup d'après on en sert rien
Alors le jeu sur le temps de réaction
je suis très mauvais à ça
je suis très mauvais dans les jeux vidéos où il faut réagir très vite
dans ce jeu il avait fini dans le top 91%
Moi je vais être dans le top 1%
Allez c'est parti. Il y a 5 essais
dès que c'est vert faut cliquer
307 millisecondes
je sais que c'est beaucoup
je sais que c'est trop. Allez on continue
c'est plus long. Bien que j'avais l'impression d'être plus rapide
je vais garder la souris dans la main en fait. Je suis débile aussi
326 mais comment je peux faire, plus nul, au fur et à mesure
il reste 2 essais
258 OUI
Je suis dans le top 41%
Squeezie, cher maitre
vous gagnez cette manche
Dans ce jeu là il va nous donner des mots
et au fur et à mesure on va dire si ce mot on l'a déjà vu passer
ou si il est nouveau
c'est à dire que c'est les méta-données
Notre cerveau sait ce qu'il a déjà vu
ou sait ce qu'il a déjà entendu
par contre je vais bien regarder l'écran je vais me concentrer
parce que c'est pas forcément simple surtout avec des mots qui sont pas en français
C'est à dire que je ne vais pas connaitre le sens de chaque mot
j'ai perdu une vie, je l'ai même pas vu sur quel mot?
c'est pas grave
on est à 69 sur le score qu'avait fait Squeezie
70 c'est bon
même un petit 71 si vous voulez
ou un 72
ou un 73
ou un 74
ou un 75 bon bref
on l'a battu donc on s'arrête là
comme tout à l'heure si vous voulez que je fasse ce jeu là jusqu'en entier vous me le direz
Pour l'instant, je l'ai battu sur 2 manches. Il m'a battu sur une manche
virtuellement. Parce que malheureusement Squeezie ne m'a pas proposé de faire un jeu ensemble
Donc 4ème et dernier jeu
celui là il est un petit peu chaud
pour moi en tout cas. J'ai pas une très bonne mémoire... de localisation
Lucas avait fait plus de 13000 points
j'ai des doutes sur ma perf
c'est à dire que si je perds on sera à équalité
C'est nul l'égalité
Hop ! Alors jusqu'ici tout vas bien.
Je suppose que le damier il va augmenter au fur et à mesure
En fait, là où il est très fort Squeezie c'est d'arriver à vous parler en même temps
moi je n'y arrive pas quand je me concentre, je me concentre
c'est compliqué pour moi de te causer comme ça en même temps
En fait, il faut vraiment visualiser des formes à la tetris dans sa tête quoi
faut ce créer un dessin mentalement
Là ça devient chaud quand même
arghh je sais plus
je ne me souviens plus de cette ligne
Je sais qu'il va y avoir un trou
ouhhh j'ai pris cher là
J'ai pris super cher
Plus qu'une vie
celui là ça va il est simple
Et après il y en avait en haut aussi
[En rigolant] Alors ils sont où?
Je sais plus du tout où ils sont
Combien? 17000 ! Ben c'est bon !
17000. Et bien c'est pas si mauvais ça 17000
Squeezie il avait fait 13945.
Donc c'est bon. Ce qui veut dire que virtuellement je remporte cette manche
Si on avait jouer ensemble l'un contre l'autre le 24 mai dernier
J'aurai rapporté la partie.
Merci à lui de m'avoir fait découvrir le jeu dans sa vidéo.
Et du coup, si vous, vous ne connaissiez pas le jeu. Je vous mets le lien dans la description
ainsi que le lien vers la chaîne de Squeezie
Parce que si vous connaissez pas ces vidéos
c'est que vous habitez une autre planète
donc allez voir ce qu'il fait
Sinon pour les prochaines dédicaces
sachez que je serai le 28 juin 2017 à Mondeville à côté de Caen
à Cultura à 14h30 jusqu'à 16h30
Pour dédicacer le livre si vous ne savez pas de quoi parle livre
il y a un lien vers la vidéo dans la description
Il y aura d'autres dédicaces qui se mettront en place  à la rentrée
Je vous dirai ça le moment venu
Maintenant je vous invite à sortir votre crayon
"Placement de produiiit" Non je cache la marque
Pour noter, quelque part sur votre main où vous voulez
Que la prochaine vidéo elle va sortir mercredi à 17h30 ici sur la chaîne
Elle parlera de mentaliste et de non verbal
avec le regard. Les directions du regard
Vous savez des choses dessus
Et bien on va en reparler. On va aller plus loin mercredi prochain
Comme d'habitude si la vidéo vous a plu,
vous savez que vous pouvez faire quelque chose pour l'envoyer un peu plus vers le ciel
et vous pouvez également vous abonner à la chaîne
et donc rendez vous mercredi à 17h30 Tchao !